police say the train began experiencing
problems just outside of the town of
sirhari behind me you can see the
derailed cars sitting here on the side
of the tracks but the point of impact
seems to be this bridge a train car
seemingly jumped tracks and hit this
bridge at medium speed one witness told
us that this train car was the one from
which they pulled the largest number of
dead bodies from this wreckage and we
can still see clothes shoes personal
belongings strewn everywhere things that
no one is going to be coming back for
now the train system in Pakistan is a
British era infrastructure project it is
outdated it needs to be modernized and
it is still a vital part of Pakistan's
economy of Pakistan's transport system
an indication of that is that just less
than 24 hours after this
repair work has begun to get this vital
transport link back online
foreign